in this video we look at parallel lines
and
planes how would you define parallel
lines we know that intersecting lines
are the lines that meet at a point so
our lines which do not meet
parallel like line P and line Q here
they don't meet even if they're extended
or maybe we can call them lines which do
not intersect are these definitions
correct correct this is how most of the
students Define it and it is not
completely correct let us erase this and
see why consider a plane suppose we have
line p on the plane a and line Q passing
through the plane a like this
perpendicular to it these lines will
never meet are lines p and Q parallel
then they never meet but the answer is
no they are not parallel lines let us
understand the complete definition of
parallel lines lines which lie on the
same plane and do not intersect are
called parallel
lines consider line C and line D if they
lie on one plane and they do not meet
each other then lines C and D are called
parallel lines so that's the complete
definition of parallel lines lines which
lie on the same plane and do not
intersect
but what are parallel planes it's simple
they are planes which do not intersect
if we have plane a and plane B which do
not intersect they are called parallel
planes and the best example of parallel
planes is opposite surfaces of a cube
let this be our Cube let us name all the
vertices of the cube so that we can
identify the planes easily let a b c d
be the front face and let e f g and H be
the back
face every pair of opposite planes in a
cube is parallel to consider an example
we can say that the top and the bottom
surfaces are parallel to each other
plane a DFG is parallel to plane
BC
[Music]